je vous remercie d'être avec nous sur rt
france alors d'après le gendarme
britannique du traitement de données
c'est du droit à l'image
il n'y aurait donc aucune preuve
tangible d'une ingérence de cambridge
analytique est dans le référendum sur le
brésil en 2016 ce que vous êtes
convaincus par les conclusions de cette
enquête
oui il pourrait placer un peu le sujet
rappelons que cette société cambridge
analytique hommes avaient recueilli des
données personnelles sur facebook
en fait en utilisant facebook qui est un
quiz sur sur facebook qu'elle avait
lancée et sans demander le consentement
des utilisateurs ont leur expliquons
curé des données recueillies
c'est pas joli joli mais on sait que
c'est tous les utilisateurs
toutes les grandes sociétés du web font
cela et c'est un vrai problème c'est
vrai que vous rappeler c'est que ce sont
les médias progressistes qui sur toutes
les ondes et dans toute la presse ont
lancé une énorme campagne pour dire que
le président avait été truqué que
cambridge analytica avait réussi à
influencer à truquer le breakbeat donc
et que grosso modo c'était les
progressistes ont perdu les
mondialisateurs ont perdu parce que nos
adversaires ont truqué pour la
commission dit que quand béchade lundi
qu'il n'était pas impliqué là dedans
donc là les médias progressistes et
mondialisateurs sont pris en flagrant
délit de complotisme c'est cocasse puis
sans arrêt leur adversaire populiste
d'être complotistes alors sans avoir
jamais preuve et en lançant des
arguments comme celui là en fait ce sont
eux qui ont été complotistes sur ce coup
or vous dites complotistes mais on a
quand même pu écouter
le témoignage de d'anciens salariés de
cambridge analytique et qui font état
aussi d'une influence de cambridge
analytique est sûre ce référendum sur le
brésil en 2016 comme qu'est ce que vous
dites de ces témoignages ils sont moi ce
que je remarque c'est que aider des
lanceurs d'alert peuvent raconter des
choses un petit peu bizarre c'est comme
aux états unis il ya un lanceur d'alerté
qui a expliqué que trump avait travaillé
avec les russes et les russes avaient
influencé la campagne on a vu que le
dossier était complètement vide
l enquête a fait pschitt alors qu'elle a
été relayée sur toutes les ondes
alors ça pose un problème en fait plus
large de recueil des données
personnelles en fait des gens qui se
fait principalement d'ailleurs par les
gaffes a qui sont inspirés et qui
permettent des manipulations toutes les
manipulations les manipulations
politiques des manipulations privée
puisque cela permet de faire acheter ou
aux gens des choses dont ils ont pas
spécialement de besoin ou de changer
leur avis sur telle entreprise ou telles
ong et malheureusement la france ne peut
rien faire là dessus pour l'instant
puisqu'elle a perdu sa souveraineté
numérique ce sont les gaffes un
américain qui règne en france et qui
dictent leur loi et la france est très
faible en la matière mais moi je vais
vous donner un exemple vraiment assez
extraordinaire de manipulation et qui
émettent du côté du clan camp des
progressistes plus tôt c'est en fait en
il y à une information très importante
qui est sorti dans le journal le sun
britannique qui montrait une ancienne
responsable de l'innovation chez la
responsable même de l'innovation qui
s'appelle adrienne genii chez google qui
disait que la situation trump ne se
passait plus ne se passeraient plus en
caméra cachée elle disait en fait que
l'élection de tram google ferait tout
pour se battre contre eux trompe alors
cette vidéo est disponible sur internet
bien entendu par tous les moteurs de
recherche vous tapez le trump stop
actions dans les hausses le titre the
sun dans un moteur de recherche et vous
obtiendrez cette vidéo que je vous
conseille de voir
en revanche elle n'est pas disponible
sauve google bien entendu qui cache
l'article du sun puisqu'il est impliqué
là dedans autre fait qui montrent qu'il
ya une vraie manipulation de google dans
ce sujet à ce sujet en fait vous
chercher ian genii et vous ne trouvez
plus rien sur google que rien sur
linkedin
tout a été effacé alors même que
d'anciennes conférence il ya quelques
traces quand même d'anciennes conférence
où elle apparaît comme responsable de
l'innovation chez google ne peuvent être
retrouvés parce que google n'a pas
réussi à les effacer où les trouver donc
on voit qu'il ya de la manipulation et
cette manipulation se fait très souvent
par bien entendu ceux qui ont les outils
de manipulation c'est à dire les plus
puissants qui sont très généralement les
progressistes et les mondialisateurs et
qu'est ce qu'elle change cette enquête
est ce qu'elle est crédibilise davantage
est-ce qu'elle appuie davantage sur
cette volonté est bien du peuple
britannique de vouloir sortir de l'union
européenne c'est ça crédibilise cette
volonté là oui oui toute manière
personne ne pouvait croire qu'une
société pouvait influencer comme ça le
vote des britanniques il n'y a pas de
fausses choses qui avaient été lancées
il ya tous les journaux progressiste de
l'autre côté mais moi ce qui m'inquiète
plus si vous voulez c'est que en fait du
monde de manipulation pour les montres
entrer dans un monde de surveillance
généralisée et de privation de liberté -
c'est ça qui m'inquiète les données
personnelles sont inspirés on sait que
par exemple en france on a aussi les
passeports biométriques le gouvernement
en 2019 a expliqué qu'il voulait faire
des tests pour coupler les passeports
biométriques aux caméras de surveillance
le gouvernement français
et ça c'est très gênant parce que ça
pourrait permettre de savoir à tout
moment comme vous passez devant une
caméra où vous êtes
où est l personnes tel citoyen français
donc pourquoi surveille qu'il tenait
pour punir et lampes ans aux traits
noirs qui se passe en chine où les
caméras de surveillance ont couplé à la
reconnaissance biométrique ce qui permet
au gouvernement chinois de surveiller
tous les citoyens et de les punir de les
empêcher de prendre le train d'acheter
des billets 30 de voyager par exemple
ils se sont pas des bons citoyens
ça c'est vraiment extrêmement inquiétant
cette volonté de surveillance et de
punitions généralisée et il n'y a qu'une
seule chose qui pourra permettre de
sauver les citoyens français de cela en
tout 400 préserver si jamais les élites
voulait aller surveiller trop trop
fortement pour les punir
c'est le référent dans le citoyenne qui
leur permettra d'empêcher ce type de
lois de se mettre en place je pense que
c'est un débat extrêmement important
pour la ville s'il est mort hermès et
d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes économiste
souverainiste